[Music]
shares of gamestop a struggling video
game retailer were worth just under
three dollars earlier in the pandemic
but within weeks in 2021 they went from
17
to a peak of 468 and
most of those gains happened in just one
week one of the wildest moments in wall
street history
gamestop shot up as much as 500 percent
even as many wall street professionals
had bet it would fall to near zero
because pretty much their business is in
terminal decline that whole
drama really accelerated within the span
of a week which just shows you
how quickly these events can play out
when so many people are
talking about it online what makes this
rally unique
is that it was driven by individual
investors using apps like robinhood
and watching youtube videos tweets from
celebrities like elon musk
and the now famous wall street bets
reddit page
wall street bets on reddit gamestop what
is going going on in the reddit
community now that is
insane you're seeing a huge number of
people
on these commission free trading apps
able to make trades just from their
mobile phone really quickly
and a huge number of people discussing
these trades on social media
together i think those two forces
combined to
produce what we've been seeing the last
week which is basically this social
media driven trading frenzy
we looked at how the game stopped
trading craze spread online and turned
wall street upside down during one
wild week in january gamestop's frantic
trading week
started on the website reddit people
have gathered on a popular page
or subreddit called wall street bets
since 2012
but on january 25th the subreddit's most
popular post
was this gme yolo update
gme is gamestop's stock ticker symbol
and yolo means you only live once
the post had a screenshot of an
investment summary from a massachusetts
resident named keith gill
or as he's known on reddit dfv short for
something we
can't say in this video he also goes by
roaring kitty on youtube
this was a true yolo for me when when i
was building this position
last year we had nowhere close to a
million dollars
cheers everybody the screenshot from the
34 year old who until recently worked in
marketing
showed that he had more than 13 million
dollars in gamestop stocks
options and cash the replies to the post
were largely praising gill
some saying they're jumping in to buy
gamestop shares as well with
a lot of rocket emojis to keep all hands
and feet inside the rocket as they
launched gamestop stock to the moon
much of the gamestop trading wasn't just
buying and selling shares
but also a lot of complex transactions
such as options contracts
which allow investors to bet on how the
price of a stock will rise or
fall there was so much activity that
gamestop trading was halted multiple
times that day
the company's stock actually closed
lower at 76 dollars but
stood out as the most heavily traded
stock in the s p 500
on january 26 gamestop got a huge boost
tesla ceo elon musk chimed in tweeting
gamestunk with a link to the wall street
bets subreddit
stonk is a term widely used by online
investors to talk about stock trading
the tweet was liked over 251 000 times
and got more than 38 000 retweets
elon musk's tweet was kind of another
one of those
unbelievable moments in this whole saga
because you suddenly saw everyone
talking about this
like celebrities you know business
owners
executives people you thought would
never be
following this forum and following this
gamestop drama
another popular tweet came from chamoth
pauli hapatia
a venture capitalist and former facebook
executive
he said he bought calls on gamestop
meaning he was betting the share price
would continue to rise
by the time markets closed on tuesday
gamestop's share price was up to 147
dollars
and on january 27th i think that what
you're seeing
is um essentially a push back
against the establishment in a really
important way
gme went mainstream making headlines
around the world
social media average joes versus big
money players video game retailer
gamestop is set to continue their head
spinning ascent today
it's wall street's david versus goliath
that whole frenzy kind of
caught the attention of a lot of people
i mean i talked to some people
on twitter and on reddit who had never
traded before but they just saw what was
happening with gamestop and
they sort of couldn't resist it was kind
of like a fomo moment
the wall street bets reddit page
temporarily went private with
moderators citing technical difficulties
on an unprecedented scale as a result of
the newfound interest in wsb
the stock closed at 347
but then robin hood just absolutely
screwed over all the retail investors
today this is madness
this is absolute madness on january 28th
the popular trading platform robin hood
restricted trading of hot stocks
including gamestop giving users only two
options
hold or sell but not buy gamestop shares
plummeted
robinhood said it restricted some
trading on its platform because it
needed more money to pay its
clearinghouse
which processes trades on the back end
due to increased activity
other brokerage firms like weeble
financial and e-trade had also
restricted trading of gamestop
citing challenges in providing their
normal services
robin hood got a lot of backlash as its
brand is built around the idea of making
investment more accessible
that was i think a real flashpoint
i think it really added to the sense of
anger and the sort of victim mentality
that was growing because
a lot of these individuals who had just
seen these stocks doing really well
tried to get in on the action and then
saw overnight that they were unable to
do so
politicians across the aisle including
alexandria ocasio-cortez
and ted cruz tweeted their support for a
hearing on robin hood's decision to
restrict
trading at markets close gamestop's
share price settled around 193 dollars
after peaking at roughly 468.
at the end of the week gamestop stock
was worth 328 dollars
that's up 1600 in 2021.
it's been crazy out there what started
off as a unique market strategy
has evolved into class warfare and a
full-on market rebellion
gme trading eventually resumed on robin
hood though it was still limited
and gamestop shares rose again wall
street bets was full of memes
investment screenshots and members
celebrating the fact that they made a
real impact on wall street
in an exclusive interview with the wall
street journal keith gill
said he didn't expect this story to get
so big i think
there was a real acknowledgement of how
surreal this moment was that
wall street bats had become the center
of this drama
and had actually become this serious
thing that people were talking about
because a lot of the users would say
that it's sort of
it started out as a joke in just one
week wall street bets membership had
grown from 2.1 million
to 6.4 million and google searches for
gamestop had nearly doubled
what a crazy thing to be looking at here
this is gamestop's chart
looking at the daily just absolute
insanity the dramatic trading frenzy has
also brought scrutiny from the white
house
congress and the sec with planned
hearings and
calls for an investigation and tighter
regulation
and robin hood faced a number of class
actions from users over its trading
restrictions
gamestop is still mostly a traditional
brick and mortar company
selling video games and consoles in
malls and by february 2nd
its stock value had dropped to 90
dollars
while some redditors made millions
trading gamestop
other retail investors who bought when
the price was high are likely nursing
big losses
but gamestop has changed the debate
about the democratization of the stock
market and
the power of individual investors online
with wall street bets newfound following
the reddit crowd has already targeted
other stocks and assets and demonstrated
that it can have an
impact on markets i think for me the
biggest takeaway is that you cannot
ignore the individual it's something to
behold and it teaches
us that this moment can sort of
replicate itself in many other ways like
we it doesn't have to just be
a game stop we've already seen it's it's
moved on to silver prices
it's moved on to other things that you
wouldn't have necessarily thought about